on va maintenant passer quelques coups
de fil minceur là on tombe sur un
répondeur
interview répondeur bonjour bonjour vous
êtes bien c'est pierre lescure je vais
bien merci
je bosse sur la 5e et j'ai vendu tous
mes meubles laissez moi un message bip
j'ai vu ce que tu veux sur la cinquième
c'est pas mal qui devrait prendre une
chaîne de télé ouais bonjour vous êtes
bien chez monsieur madame gaccio oui on
est les parents on est désolé laissez un
message bip je t'appelle demain je te
jure
bonjour vous êtes bien chez michèle
bernier si vous n'êtes pas bruno gaccio
laissé un message bip
je ne suis pas bruno gaccio moi je suis
bruno gaccio g comment vont les enfants
michel à bonjour vous êtes bien chez
florent pagny vous pouvez me laisser un
message
mais vous n'aurez pas ma liberté de
pensée bip me spira excuses - laurent
florent ce que je me suis gouré alors je
sais j'ai fait un faux numéro je voulais
appeler quelqu'un d'autre en fait je
l'appellerai bonjour c'est bien chez le
procureur philippe bilger
je suis parti faire le guignol à la télé
et bruno gaccio laissez moi un message
bip est plus drôle que bruno gaccio
bonjour j'ai bien c'est jacques et
bernadette chirac
si vous avez des pièces jaunes laissez
nous un message bip dit alors en fait on
devrait en vrai vous lier ensemble donc
bonjour vous êtes bien chez patrick
sébastien je me suis fait une tête de
répondeur c'est génial fois laissé un
message bip continue à faire des
missions de service public c'était juste
pour dire ça que je te plait je dirais
j'aime bien les saltimbanques
il est mérité pour manquer oui bonjour
vous êtes bien c'est jean marie le pen
je voulais sortir avec ma fille laissez
moi un message mais jean-marie je
voudrais bien sortir avec ta fille qui
j'aimerais bien que tu sortes avec ta
fille que tu sortes du pays avec ta
fille que tu sors
bonjour bonjour vous êtes bien chez
guillaume durand [ __ ] je bosse comme
un fou
laissez moi un message pardon tu bosse
comme un fou ouais ça leur jeu bonjour
c'est bien c'est laurent baffie si vous
avez vu mon fils laissez moi un message
bip
j'ai pas vu ton film long du jeu
j'attends qu'il sorte en dvd ouais c'est
bientôt en plus laurence et gaccio
arrête de faire la gueule
un bonjour j'ai bien chez lionel jospin
je vais revenir laissez-moi messagerie
mais rosien lyonnais leurs biens ah
ouais bah oui mais tu kiffes abuse au
long du ve quoi vont peut-être un autre
et qui il va rien comprendre au message
bonjour vous êtes bien c'est george
boole je sais que c'est incroyable
laissez moi un message bip laisse gagner
qui arrive quand je t'entends pas laisse
gagner kerry on te dit je laisse gagner
kerry ouais georges laisse gagner oui
bah oui non la vie du monde en dépend je
vais vrai c'est vrai et oui non c'est
pourquoi on s'intéresse pas aux
élections et dauphine allemande mono
bonjour vous êtes bien chez
l'association des personnes de petite
taille de france si vous n'êtes pas trop
grand laissez moi un message vip pour à
m
je vous dis qu'au basket d'accord
bonjour vous êtes bien celle d'espèces
laissez moi un message on sait jamais
bip
quand est ce que tu fais un disque
revient revient vite ils sont tous
devenus fous ils ont listé leurs
encadrants la panique
lol